the most powerful things that change our
behavior and our character are the
stories we tell ourselves
i think that when i started out in
business uh i've heard i heard all these
things in the personal development space
like uh you should have you should read
these affirmations every morning blah
blah blah
i never did that and it was because it
felt stupid to me now that being said
there might be some people who've had
life-changing results from doing that
but what i did notice is that the
stories i would tell myself about myself
were the things that changed my beliefs
they were the things that changed my
character
and so a lot of times in some of my
other videos i've talked about how
entrepreneurship is about three things
it's about changing the beliefs that you
have
it's about increasing the skill set that
you have and then the character traits
that go along with that to make sure the
skills are successful so i'll give you a
simple example for this so a friend of
mine he started a fitness app um he was
doing about twenty thousand a month he
was a top game uh crossfit games
competitor um but he was really ashamed
because he wasn't the winner he was like
you know really really highly ranked one
but he wasn't the winner and so he
believed that his app wasn't good enough
and so he never promoted it so it grew
to 20 000 a month in revenue with him
doing zero promotion right
and
when he realized that it was okay for
him to promote it and people got a lot
of value from it in the app was good
enough he went from 20 000 a month to
like 150 000 a month like that
and the difference was
his beliefs
his skills were the same right his
character traits are the same he changed
his beliefs right so let me give you a
different example so when i actually
started out getting in my own business
right i uh i had a chain of gyms this
was a very very you know this was ten
years ago i had changed gyms i
knew how to run sales teams i knew how
to generate leads i need to do all these
things um but what ended up happening
was i had one missing piece which was
also a belief darn i was actually trying
to give you a different one but i had a
mentor come in and say you need to be
you need to get in the licensing
business you need to license this model
to lots of people rather than doing the
actual model yourself and so um i did
make that transition and then we went
from i think you know i think we did
like two or three million dollars to
doing seven and the next year we did 28
million so the year that we made the
transition halfway through is what
jumped us from two or three to seven and
it was just in the last like four months
that we saw this crazy growth and then
we did 28 million the next year and so
it was because i had all these skills
and i also had the character traits i
just needed again to change my beliefs i
was trying to give you an example with
the character traits let me think of one
so if you have uh for example if i had
had those skills but i didn't have the
character traits of being disciplined
and being focused on one thing i would
have jumped uh between multiple you know
entrepreneurial endeavors and never been
able to see success because even though
i had the beliefs about what was
possible um like if i'd said okay i'm
gonna do gyms and i'm gonna do
chiropractors and i'm gonna do dentists
i'm gonna do x y and z right
until i had the character trait of focus
the character trait of discipline um
then i would not have seen the success
right and so the next natural question
is okay well if i have to have aligned
beliefs skills and character traits at
each level of the ladder because you can
have and this is what's crazy when you
see the overnight successes this is what
happens i want to describe it to you so
you understand it and how you can do it
so let's say that there's a ladder all
right and you've got this pole on one
side you've got the pole on the other
side and you've got the middle bar okay
you need all three to move to the next
level of the ladder right and so for
example you might have the left side
built up
six stories above where you're at and
you might have uh the right side build
up six stories you know uh are you know
ten stories from where you're at right
now but all of a sudden if you change
your character and that character trait
development gives you three more rungs
all of a sudden you go three rungs
because you already have the constraint
has been removed and so you can be more
advanced in your beliefs than you on
your skills or it can be more advanced
in your character trait than you are in
your skills or you can be more advanced
in your skills than your own your
beliefs right and so it's having all
three of those that are checked off at
each level of entrepreneurship that gets
you to one one million dollars a year
three million or ten million dollars or
a hundred million dollars or whatever it
is right is you have to have all of them
and so what i the point of this video
and i'm gonna is is to get you to
understand how to actually develop those
soft things because the skills are
straightforward right the skills are you
just go by the course and you read the
book and you consume the content like
this and you practice you apply right
that's what you have to do that's it
that's it right um one of the skills
that i see lots of marketers these days
not have is they don't know how to sell
they don't know how to develop a sales
team they don't know how to manage and
grow a sales team they don't want to
lead a sales team that's a skill they
don't have and as soon as they do they
go from 3 million to 10 million like
that very very easily right it's
understanding that that's the skill
deficit and as soon as they do it boom
they blow up i was fortunate because i
had a ton of the skills in my skill
toolbox but i went from making nothing
to tons because i had all of these rungs
of this ladder already built out to a 30
million dollar level except i just
didn't have the beliefs
that was my issue candidly i suffer from
a lot of insecurities and so
my wife was the one who was like you can
do this like you don't have to have
these gyms like you can license out the
model like you can you can really
succeed like this and i honestly just
thought she was a really smart person
and very wise and so i trusted her
belief in me
before i really trusted it for myself
and so hopefully you can have something
like that in your life but maybe that
that could be me i trust in your i trust
in your your skills and your beliefs so
so hopefully you can borrow some of that
trust because i promise you the world
does get better when you when you take
those leaps of faith but the point is is
if you have these three things right
the stories that you tell yourself right
one of the things that layla always says
is my wife she has her own channel you
can check it out um is she's like what's
the evidence right what's the evidence
that you're so bad at this what's the
evidence that you have cause you keep
beating yourself up about this but
what's your evidence right and so what i
do when i identify a character trait
that i lack or identify a skill that i
don't have or a belief that i don't have
and this one i'll just specifically talk
about the character traits because i
think it's really important it's
probably the one that people struggle
with the most what are the stories that
you tell yourself about yourself right a
lot of times i had dinner recently with
a 5 million year entrepreneur and he was
like i had a lot of trauma when i was a
kid and that's why i am this way he
speaks like he is this way because
and i was like i think that's a really
convenient story to tell yourself about
why you are anxious
or why you exhibit anxious tendencies i
was like but what if you did that and
you just didn't exhibit anxious
tendencies
what then
what if you just chose not to
what if you chose to not give power to
that situation or that parent
uh when you were growing up why why they
already made you suffer why would you
let them make you suffer more by telling
yourself that they gave you this
character trait then it's because it's
uncomfortable for you to suffer through
the change of changing your identity
right but layla and i both believe this
is that your identity is fluid and you
need to be able to change your identity
and your character traits based on what
the business requires if you want to
grow right like if you're not a patient
person
then you need to become patient macro
micro speed macro patients right if you
want to develop a reputation you need to
become a person of integrity which means
sometimes short term you have to
sacrifice right you have to not make the
quick buck if you want to be disciplined
and have focus and it means that you
have to be able to say no
strategy means what do you say no to
that still looks like it makes sense on
paper that's strategy that's what it is
it's what things do we choose not to
invest in right and the people who learn
how to make the most money are the ones
who know how to focus and that's a
character trait and so what you have to
do is you have to appeal in your past
and say when did i exhibit these things
because all of us have exhibited these
character traits at some point in our
life
and then what you do is you say i am
this way because and then you tell
yourself the stories of the things you
did in the past that exhibited those
traits
and by doing that you'll start reminding
yourself so if i want to say like
because i'll tell you i used to have
more angry tendencies i used to tend and
trend towards being angry as a response
to things that i didn't like right but
one of the things that i liked like that
i try and tell myself is that i am wise
right and this is a character trait
that's probably been the number one
character trait that i've tried to
develop over the however many years just
because i believe discernment is the
single greatest character trait you can
have because if you make the right
decisions
the whole world is your oyster right if
you can make the right call
the whole world is your oyster and so
for me wisdom is the number one
character trait that i wish to develop
and so when i think to myself i am wise
because i use the same
formula that you that most people and
most of us myself included use to
destroy ourselves with these
insecurities with these with these
negative character traits that we
believe we have
and instead of saying an affirmation you
tell yourself the story of why what
you're saying is true you learn to argue
against your own thoughts and that's how
you start developing this muscle this
these traits that start to become a
whisper and then a shout and then they
become they emanate from you and you
project them when you walk in the room
subconsciously but it's a practice that
goes from active to passive in your mind
right if you are a patient person if you
are a kind person if you are an integris
person right if you're a hard-working
person right we all have these stories
that we tell about ourselves and so
if you have a limitation right now on
your character trait
or traits you don't feel like you are
patient enough you feel like you are too
easily distracted you feel like you
don't focus enough then you need to
start telling yourself the story i am
this way because
not i am wealthy stupid in my opinion i
think our brains are too smart for that
stuff you have to give it the reasons
you have to make the argument and i
think instead of affirmations if you
make affirmations into arguments that
you make with yourself every day then
those become things that will change who
you are and if you change who you are
and how you make decisions you'll change
your entire life and you'll be able to
watch your business grow as a result of
who you have become
and so this is one of the things that
was most powerful for me in my
entrepreneurial journey i
had
had tons of insecurities right i had
tons of anxieties i had lots of anger i
had lots of perceived trauma and i'll
say it that way because i don't even
want to make it into trauma that's what
i perceived as trauma because i was a
child in the world with the the regular
the emotional regulation of a child and
so things of course affect you more when
your kid everyone's traumatized
traumatized perceives trauma as a child
like if i go to a stage and i say hey
who here had a traumatic childhood in
some instance or had a traumatic event
occur everyone's going to raise their
hand so stop thinking that because you
have trauma and i don't say this i'll
say this with it i'll say it this way
better
for me
i chose to stop giving trauma
power
and i think if you can do that and you
can tell yourself a different story
about why you are who you are
and make arguments instead of
affirmations you'll be able to have
stronger faster change in the direction
that you desire and you'll have more
control over your emotional state and
then in so doing you'll be able to level
up the business that you have because
most of times when i see business owners
the reason they're not successful is not
because they don't have the beliefs or
because they don't have the skills it's
just because of who they are i'd call
the other day and somebody hopped on and
they were like ah and honestly the guy
was an [ __ ]
he was like man employees suck and i can
never keep any good talent blah blah
blah blah and i just paused and i was
like
that's not surprising and he was like
what i was like have you met you
like i don't know what else to say
have you met you like i don't need to
change this guy's marketing right i
don't need to change this guy's beliefs
about his own business he's just to
change who he is
right
and the only way for that guy to do that
is for him to get over the reasons that
he tells himself it's okay to be who he
is
and i think a lot of us do that we give
ourselves the excuse for being impatient
we give ourselves the excuse for
cheating right we give ourselves the
excuse for being unfaithful you get the
excuse for being unloyal well my dad was
where my mom was or my brother was or
whatever
right or when i was growing up or went
from my town i xyz
i'm this way because the cows is one of
the most powerful words in the english
language it's great for persuasion make
sure you use it to persuade yourself in
the right direction so anyways that's
just my two cents i might not know
anything um if you found value in this
hit subscribe i have other videos that
like this for entrepreneurs who are
trying to uh scale their businesses uh
keeping awesome keep being amazing lots
of love mosey national guys see you guys
in the next video bye